A lot of us are not thrilled with the social
distancing and the same self-isolation that
we're doing.
But one of the unintended side effects of
all this is that the climate is doing much
better than it has in a long time because
so much activity has been curtailed and shut
down.
And this applies to air pollution.
This applies to water quality.
In some places.
It's actually incredible and it confirms that
we can do a lot when it comes to the climate.
If we commit to it and hopefully once this
is all over, it will serve as an instructive
period.
I'm worried it won't.
I'm worried a lot of people won't want to
accept it as a reality.
But this is very clear.
Let's look at a few examples.
In Venice, the water in the canals is very
clear because for decades you've had constant
boat traffic moving tourists around the canals,
which has stopped.
Now the water has cleared up dramatically
in countries like China, where industrial
activity has slowed down.
They are having the cleanest air that they've
had in a very long time.
We have a picture up of nitrogen levels in
the atmosphere in January
and then in February above China.
It is a night and day difference is the drastic
flight cancelations have been terrible for
airlines business.
It's been horrible for people wanting to go
visit family or whatever else they want to
do.
But it has significantly reduced pollution
around the world.
Over in Italy, more generally, pollution levels
are down.
Also, nitrogen dioxide falling drastically
in the space above Italy.
Now, of course, if we do nothing with this
information, it's a factoid.
It's academic.
Maybe it's interesting.
As soon as the virus starts to pass, everything
goes right back to where it was.
But look at how quickly things improved in
areas where so many people are defeatist and
they say we can't be done.
It's too big of a task.
Look at how quickly as soon as a lot of this
activity was reduced, not eliminated, remember,
but reduced.
We see things improve dramatically.
Now, it's not realistic to think once the
virus passes, we stay shut down.
It would never happen.
I'm not suggesting that we do that.
But if anything, there are some lessons here.
One is a lot of stuff can be done from home.
Number to a ton of stuff that was previously,
you
know, an hour meeting that might involve 10
people driving around to go to the same place
can be figured out by email or at most, you
know, a teleconference call instead of everybody
driving to the same place.
Number three, a ton of stuff that people did
in their jobs isn't even necessary at all.
It's what we would call unnecessary busywork.
Never mind what can be done by email instead
of in meetings.
Number four, we actually can get by with a
lot less moving around.
And of course, not all jobs can be performed
remotely, but many jobs can.
A lot of the driving around to go to meetings
and sit in offices is just not necessary.
We've known this at the David Packman show
for a long time, but look at reducing commute
times.
Look at reducing pollution.
Imagine if everybody that could work from
home did work from home permanently.
You're talking about eliminating annoying
commutes, environmentally destructive commutes
for so mental.
So many people.
You're improving mental health for people
who no longer have to sit in a car.
Predominantly people sitting in cars, going
to work, coming back from work that time can
instead be used for reading or for going for
a bike ride or for whatever else.
And people have been doing this.
People have been
saying, I'm getting just as much done working
less from home the time I'd spend commuting.
I'm actually making breakfast rather than
getting, you know, a cup sit, 600 calorie
frappe, a thing or whatever.
I'm riding my bike in the time I would normally
be commuting home or whatever the case may
be.
Now, this doesn't apply to a lot of people
in many industries.
Health care workers, heroes during what's
going on.
Grocery store workers, of course.
But there are some major lessons here.
And I actually wonder whether after this is
all said and done, it leads to a decline in
populations in some of the really expensive
major cities, because one of the reason that
a lot of people make what for them is a sacrifice
of paying a lot more to live in an expensive
city or to commute into an expensive city.
And having
a really long commute is because they believe
they have to be there for their job.
If both they and their employers realize you
could be anywhere to do the job, I would not
be surprised if you start seeing people moving
to lower cost of living areas while keeping
their jobs and working remotely.
It's speculative.
We're not going to know for a while how this
shakes out.
We're still in the middle of a crisis, but.
The amount that so many employers and employees
have learned from this is quite stunning.
And I'm sure we will be studying it for a
long
time
to
come